okay guys i'm gonna give it a second
i gotta call eva
anna um i need to know your chipotle
order now if you want it
mom's going right now
i would tell you um but for real
what do you want from chipotle okay i
want
um a steak bowl
with uh cheese white rice
okay okay
um and then
okay i'm gonna just call chaz and then
that's everyone
okay okay bye
okay hey guys sorry i have um
i need to see what everyone wants from
chipotle in the house but give me like
two seconds i swear
i started this prematurely
we'll see if he answers
do you want anything from chipotle speak
now or forever hold your peace
where are you are you here
okay okay just making sure bye
okay that made it easy why is my
charger not working that is not good
not good at all my phone
it's not like three percent hold up
okay
oh that's why my outlet's off
this die well
how much battery do i have on here
guys i'm so sorry this is so
this is so disorganized i just realized
my like
power strip died but it's okay i have 51
battery on my laptop so it's no big deal
okay how do i see what you guys are
saying
i think if i go like this oh there we go
okay
okay what do you guys want me to react
to
um
so kevin is whatever do you guys have
like a kevin samuels video you want me
to react to otherwise i'm just gonna
like google his top ones
okay so i'm gonna go to youtube
let me just see if anybody
suggested anything before i go
um okay so no one it's cool if not
i know there's like six people on here
oh god not that email
okay um
hey kevin samuels
i've looked up some of his videos before
um
but i'm not like a huge
kevin samuels fan but yeah let's see
this looks in like a click bait title
okay have you ever dancing
why can't i hear anything
if instagram i don't know whatever you
got a talent
okay first before i start the video um
let me know in the chat can you guys
hear
okay um
like the video because i got complaints
last time that the video is too quiet so
i'm going to play for like
10 seconds and then i'm going to come
back to the comments and just say like
the video sound is good or like louder
or quieter because i want to make it
like good for you guys to hear
what's in township hello hi how are you
i'm well how are you good so uh
are are women out of order today
okay so that's the the sound is okay
i know there's like nine people on here
it's good okay
anyone else higher lower cause otherwise
i can like
okay it looks like
okay cool last time they told me the
sound was too quiet so i just wanted to
make sure
if you're a dancer
instagram mama i don't know whatever you
got a talent
come to the talent show hello hi how are
you
i'm well how are you good so uh
are are women out of order today
i believe so yes all right would you put
yourself in that category
uh no i don't feel like
i'm out of border um you might want to
turn your phone down just a little bit
oh sorry uh so
are you married i'm divorced all right
uh any children yes
how many i have one do you want any more
i do so do you want to be remarried
i do all right
so what does he mean by out of order
like what what does that mean that'd be
my question
so what do you want from a future
stepfather
um we gotta hold the phone still you got
all right well i guess she wants him to
get herself a cell phone cradle
um suddenly tiffany
y'all are ruthless man i look crazy man
justin bieber come over crazy y'all just
me
for no reason and there's a future
stepfather
see i call things as i see them
like when i say at home wreckers hello
hello mr samuels how are you
am i sideways no i'm good how are you
okay i'm wonderful thank you you've been
here before
no i haven't i actually just started
listening to you
okay today and um so the question on the
table
is are women out of order today
i do feel that the
i can't say the majority of women are
out of order
but there are a lot of women out of
order because
when the black community what percentage
of women would you say oh man
a lot i don't even know the percentage
maybe over
it sounds so unfair to say over 50.
nevertheless you just look at the
culture and you listen to the music and
you see the way we're portrayed on
television and different shows
and so now they can't portray us we
don't take the rules
well that's true that is so what
percentage what percentage of a black
one would you say are out of order
well that's tough mr samuel um
i don't want to be unfair and say over
half that's my question
that's my number one problem
you ladies always so damn caring about
not being
unfair and you won't hold each other's
tasks
what does he mean by out of order does
anyone want to tell me that in the chat
like what is
let me just look really quick
um nobody can tell them anything they
don't need a man
disrespectful okay i wasn't sure if he
met like
no kids outside of marriage like
something like that or like you can't be
divorced but
nobody can tell them anything okay i
understand i'm gonna keep going
okay okay then okay then to be real
because this is the platform for being
real i will stick to my first percentage
and i would say over half percent i
could be wrong 50
um we do have you know we i say
collectively
i would say that's on the low end it is
if the jana manzant made their comment
back in 2013
that meant over 50 percent had to be
that way for her to make it
and she's saying we're still out of
order right
but this is how women stay out of order
in my opinion
you guys don't want to judge each other
i can't say i don't want to hurt her i
don't want this i don't want that
okay but understand that do you consider
yourself out of order
do you consider yourself out of order
you okay good it's kind of lagging a
little bit do you consider yourself out
of order
can you hear me okay okay i actually
want to talk for a second
i agree with this a lot because what
he's talking about there
because a lot of times like
girls i don't know why i'm like making
this small guy
a lot of times girls will just say like
girls support women or women support
women
and i don't agree with that at all
because for me personally like
it depends on the type of girl i'm not
just gonna support like any
woman or any girl that like doesn't make
sense to me
so i think that's like what he's talking
about like when you can't say anything
bad about woman like at all
when some girls are absolutely crazy
like that yeah
for that i hope not i don't care okay
good my it was lagging a little bit
um i'm in the process i am in the
process of getting back
in order of getting important if you are
in the process of getting back in order
and you are standing next to three women
who are
out of order acting out of order yes
going to judge you
accordingly because they share your
reflection
true or false would they judge me
accordingly like i'm getting
there's a group there is a group image
there's a group image there's a group
stereotype there's a
the everybody has them you ever hear
communities like white
white being be like this white men well
if black women
are out of order and you
are in order people are going to assume
you are out of order most of you are
and by you not wanting to say it they
make
you and make it bad for you okay so i
want to say what he's saying
is that if you don't call other women
out
on like acting like poorly
then you as a woman and like her as a
black woman like will be judged
based on like her peers and so it makes
her look bad so i think he's saying like
you should call out
your female friends but
i don't know like
i think like it all depends on the
situation i think some people
go out of their way to like give their
opinion too much
and you know sometimes
there are girls that like need a reality
check and nobody's talking to them about
it
so then how do we say that because i've
experienced different relationships
right some were good some were bad some
were toxic and so i've been in um
counseling for the last three years
counseling i believe in you know therapy
and stuff like that
so that's the reason why i said that
we're getting in the process of getting
back
so how would the women that
have that have because i like the old
school i believe that you'll make the
question simple
you got to make the question simple
you're not asking the question you're
just talking what's the question okay
so the question is how would the women
that have a desire to be in order what
do you suggest
that we do as far as what
as far as helping our other black women
realize that we need to get back in
in order okay this is kind of the
question i was asking because
if you see like your friend doing
something wild i feel like i'm not gonna
go out of my way to like
say anything to her unless she asks my
opinion you know
or like she's ruining her life so much
that like
you need someone to talk to uh
how you can help other women yes um
get in cooperation with a black man and
show it
be the example show it
okay this is what i agree with because i
hate
when people give advice when they're not
doing it themselves so i think that's
what he's saying
show it because whatever relationships
you chose to have
which is i chose to have you get to
choose how you respond to what happened
to you it ain't my fault or anybody else
out in the public's fault right
no one cares about my problems your
problems your traumas my traumas they're
our own
but how do you help other women how is
this like the black community you want
to help the black men
give it a black man go marry and make
some black babies to build a black
community
it's like everybody else is doing okay
how old are you
i'm 42. maybe children she looks great i
have a 16 year old
been married i have been married i was
married to her father
you guys split because of we
split because of infidelity how much to
how much cheating were you doing
i wasn't cheating um her father
was cheating yeah you you weren't
cheating at all
so so if he would have to if you had a
cell phone the entire marriage
all your communications with men no dms
no
emails no hey big head texts y'all
liking the pictures
okay oh no we were really
at least i thought we were all right how
many times did he cheat
i don't know how many times he cheated
once
how did i found out uh
i came home multiple times close to home
i came to work on a lunch break the ring
was he loved his ring i bought him a
beautiful ring
how did you find out
i basically talked to the woman that he
was that he was cheating with and it was
kind of
fun it was a co-worker so i went up to
his job and i
we had a conversation how did you find
her though how did you find him with her
i didn't catch him in the act i didn't
ask you what i'm trying to understand is
ma'am
i saw him doing this i heard he was
doing this how did you find her to talk
to how'd you even know
i knew his body language and you know i
knew his body language i watched her
and they were different you searched for
it
i guess i did first there you go thank
you ding
[ __ ] ding any [ __ ] thing because i
knew that
oh wow home wrecker there's another home
run
geez okay so don't search for it no
because apparently
because see see you came on here trying
to talk about
tell a story of how he was sloppy and
this and that and i'm asking you man
like you came home
he was nailing her in your bed none of
that happened
you just looked for you just had your
spidey senses up and you went looking
for problems
and you found one because he wouldn't
because he wasn't he wasn't doing it in
your face he wasn't making outside
babies
no diseases or messing up the family
funds or anything else like that
but you went like so many other women
wanting to burn your own house down
because
black men ain't [ __ ] and you wouldn't
found the problem you was looking for
hold on hold on hold on okay
because it is our culture for women to
be distrustful of the men and go
look for a problem i have never ever
ever cheated on anybody i've been with
but everybody i've been with has tried
to accuse me of being a cheater so
they've been gone look for stuff they've
been making [ __ ] up and i'm like you
making that [ __ ] up
so you went looking for a problem then
you went to his
job yes
oh my gosh
how is he gonna blame her
when her husband was cheating
i understand like what what he's saying
when
he's saying like if the guys do well
i don't even think he's saying this but
like i feel like he thinks that because
he was in a situation where his like
ex-wives or whatever
found out that he like they would always
accuse him of cheating like
he thinks that woman should be like
trusting of the guys maybe but like
that's crazy that's crazy
stop looking for the woman but you said
you confronted her
at the place of employment we did have
an
um at the place of employment
i mean it wasn't like an argument or
anything i don't give a [ __ ] if y'all
had high teeth
out of order ma'am what i said
i i will confess i have been out of work
son your husband who was married to you
who's the father of your child
you went for looking for reasons to
wreck your marriage instead of just
focusing on what you're supposed to be
doing and when you found out
you had you went and you wouldn't made
it be what it was
did he apologize afterwards no he didn't
apologize mr samuels and the thing about
it is i can't
barely say that i was going to look do i
shouldn't but no no no no
no no
but i'm not your girlfriend i didn't
finish the sentence because i don't want
to hear the [ __ ]
i want my question i got my question
okay this is my thing like don't you
want to be with someone that you can
trust
and how is she supposed to keep being
married to someone
oh my gosh my battery is about to die
hold on hold on how is she supposed to
keep being married to someone that she
can't trust that makes
no sense like
oh my goodness hold on guys the outlet
that i was using like kind of died
so i need to like plug in my laptop
hey yay
like diffused or something i don't even
know
oh my god i'm sorry guys
okay i'm gonna re-plug this in
okay okay i'm back
sorry guys i realized that my laptop was
like literally about to die
i think i have like a laptop like
issue let me look at the comments i'm
just cool
interesting
rich guys can cheat on their girls
why do people actually
think they have a right to cheat okay
let me just what was the question my
question
is how was this the only woman he was
cheating with
i don't know did you file for divorce i
did file for it
and how long have been divorced for
15 years 15 years uh huh
and are you and what you got now
i am currently not in a relationship
i met her husband you had a husband you
had a husband and a home
i did have a husband and a home and we
also i didn't give all the details
on one detail of saying and i'm not
trying to make excuses
i know it could sound like an excuse the
man's behavior drastically changed now
whether or not that was something
because of something it's gonna change
did it change drastically after you
confronted him or did you change no
before
before and that led me to ask the
questions as to what's going on because
we were
we were we had we i thought we were
happy okay the behavior
i can hear that yeah and he didn't say
anything
the behavior changed dramatically but he
didn't say anything
the behavior changed at home so
i gotta i gotta i got a real strange
question for you
okay because i was on a broadcast last
week where you had this very
conversation
okay if home wasn't making
him happy and you
asked what's wrong and he said nothing
do you make room for the fact that uh he
didn't think he could tell you
or that you would do anything about it i
did we actually went to marital
counseling
and everything like we made efforts too
but this before after the cheating
this was before i don't know when the
cheating started to be honest with you
but i know that we were in the process
of of doing
it's like the first year of being
married yes
we dated for three years and we were
married for one it was really strange
it was weird but then again i was young
i was 25
you know is that an excuse i was at 25
i had no idea i didn't yes it's when i
was younger
i didn't i was and i didn't have the
older women telling me no but ultimately
man
let me let me stop you right here
i can't believe that he's encouraged
like he's blaming the woman who got
cheated on i don't i don't get it
like if her if his behavior
changed like
of course she has a right to go like
trying to figure trying to figure out
like what happened
and she like doesn't seem like
one of those women that like you can't
tell her anything like she seems like
pretty normal so i don't know okay i'm
just gonna continue okay
ultimately who filed for divorce i did i
filed for the divorce i left you so you
wrecked your home because she got
cheated on what do you mean
perspective i can look at it that way
[Music]
because this is the net net of it this
is what i'm no matter how you slice it
i was young this or that he didn't leave
you said i'm out of here because he
changed
and it doesn't sound like the next 15
years have been
not all the way
no not all the way let me ask you a
question have a little bit more time let
me ask you this
so for a couple a married couple man and
woman married couple and
you know things are fine and then there
is a
change in the system a serious breakdown
on communication
at this time i was pregnant with my
daughter and this kind was embarrassing
this is too long of a question okay some
questions so
what do you do then besides going to
straight
break the marriage or breakthrough you
do your [ __ ] duty as a wife
so if the man on hold is
you do your duty what is that
serve love support i mean because
do respect ma'am you are a wife and you
had a child is it a son or a daughter
a right so you do your duty
as a wife and your husband's help me
and you try to understand what's going
on because your daughter wants to be in
the house with her daddy
absolutely she didn't want you to go
file for divorce to go live in
did you have a house or an apartment
afterwards i had an apartment afterwards
all right did you have a house before no
we lived in an apartment so it was
coming up
next net she wanted to be with her dad
true and that was nice this is the thing
do you ladies not think
marriages that last for 30 40 50 years
have dark days and bad times
and you stick through and do your effing
duty
yes but you guys have been told to go
have your happiness
and you're not happy i don't feel that
way anymore
now it's different now with the with the
growing and developing
getting the counseling and now heeding
to the council
let me help you out oh no i hear what i
100
like hear what he's saying um
when he's talking about like you can't
leave
when things get tough whatever this is
this is where i disagree with him
if you're with somebody that is going to
cheat on you
and lie to your face how are you
supposed to trust them
moving forward like is that
the same person that you married is that
the same
like like i don't know like when i'm
with someone like i want to make sure
that they're trusting caring kind
and like i just can't imagine staying
with someone after they cheated on me
like i understand there's dark times bad
things happen whatever but like
if you're with someone that's going to
lie to you and then have sex with
someone else like
that's a no for me you can go okay i'm
talking to these people
no i can't give advice get the [ __ ] out
of my channel
so that's why so i find more you angry
as
women who ain't got [ __ ] ain't never
been to with nobody
saying who can't do nothing you can't do
nothing except sit there and listen
everybody else the marriages that we
revere
in the black community were grandpa and
grandma yes
and what did you hear about when big
daddy your big momma died you hearing
all the [ __ ] that they did it's still
kind of hush-hush
right do your duty
got it that's what i would tell
what would you tell what would you tell
your daughter how about that what would
you tell your daughter
if she faced the same a similar
situation in her young marriage what
would you tell her
now from a different perspective i would
tell her that what you're telling me now
find out what's wrong ask him the
questions sit down and try to
communicate
that's all we need from you ladies is to
be honest so
thank you to the woman i just blocked
that's why the [ __ ] i can give advice
because i know what i'm talking about
[ __ ] your [ __ ] ass down and listen
and you might learn something yourself
sorry about that man and i truly hope it
works out for you
but we gotta do men have to do their
duty too
it's not for you guys to just suffer
through [ __ ]
but we have to do our duty to one
another or period
right or what do we get if we if we go
if we go in and out
in and out in and out in and out if it's
all about blissful love
we go from one situation to another can
you clarify what duty is
um that's a whole other broadcast take
it up
if you're a christian take it up with
your pastor or your god i would like to
answer that one all right thank you
bye-bye
i think it's funny that all of a sudden
women get real game goofy
when you start putting what's duty or
you know what duty is when the mo when
the man supposed to pay the bills you
know what duty is when a man is supposed
to step out in front of the bullet
but all of a sudden y'all get game goofy
when it comes down to what's duty for me
not a damn thing i feel like kevin
samuels has had like a really bad
experience with women
um it's not cheating
it's exercising options he's not blaming
her he's saying does she have a better
option now
cheating doesn't have to end
relationships are they taking care of
anything else
um i mean i understand if that's your
opinion and like
if you want to work it out like that's
totally up to you
just for me personally like if somebody
cheats on you my problem is like i want
to date somebody that's honest
kind caring and i
can't imagine someone being kind and
honest and having
a relations with someone else while he's
in a relationship or married to me
that's just um that's just my opinion i
think you if someone's acting weird you
absolutely have a right to like
look and just make sure that like
nothing's going on
um
and yeah i don't really have anything
else to add i don't disagree with him
like i think what his opinion
is that like you shouldn't be like
looking like you should be so focused on
you and what you're doing that you
shouldn't be like
have so much free time to like go
through your partner's phone or whatever
um and that's totally cool i agree with
that
um i also could see where he's coming
from when he's saying like the ups and
downs of a relationship like
you can't just quit when things get
tough
but a lot of people say rich guys can
cheat i mean they technically like
anyone
can cheat like literally like
can but would you want to be with
someone that does is the question
okay
my gosh they're trying to say that
biblical relationships
stop okay
does anyone else have a video that you
want me to
make sure that my like laptop's okay
um
do i want to go out with the guy that
said
rich guys can cheat
it's gonna be a no from me i'm not gonna
lie to you
i'm not gonna lie to you because what if
you got rich
okay um oh my goodness my mom i think is
calling me
hello okay i'm doing a live stream but
i'll be down in a second
okay bye
oh my goodness um
i was gonna react to one more video
before i left
oh but there's i'm supposed to leave in
15 minutes
okay i guess not tonight you're not rich
but if you got rich
you would think like like why would i do
that
um
but anyways i have a boyfriend
so i wouldn't anyway
but i just thought it was funny because
i was like
the last message was rich guys can cheat
so like why on earth would i
oh my gosh okay i wanted to do one more
but i have to go
because there's food and then i have to
get going
but how do i end this live stream okay
let me know in the comments do you agree
do you disagree um don't forget to
subscribe and like the video
just as much engagement as possible
because i'm really trying to make this a
career
and the more like subscribers
and engagement that i get the more
motivated that i am to create